salut c'est monsieur heureux aujourd'hui
de vous parler de samsung galaxy home
l'enceinte connectés de samsung qui
était présenté en même temps que le
galaxy note 9 900 connectés qui au final
est beaucoup plus mais beaucoup plus
qu'une enceinte connectés c'est pas
juste une boîte à vos jeux de la musique
c'est vraiment autre chose
cette enceinte se positionne au coeur de
la stratégie de samsung au coeur de sa
stratégie les objets connectés tout vous
expliquer vous allez voir c'est vraiment
super intéressant et ça je vous en parle
et
c'est en train de préparer mes affaires
je regardais je vous emmène en vacances
on parle demain demain matin on part
ensemble on va les tester pas mal de
choses on va aller tester ce drone le
hanafi certains moments je vous en
parlais déjà pris en main maintenant il
est temps d'aller tester vous emmène pas
d'une part contesté parce que jouer vous
trouvez vraiment le meilleur spot
pourvoir profiter vraiment d'image top
je vous emmène en crète comme ça on aura
un panorama de dengue voir s'amuser avec
donc on va les tester ça on va aussi
parler de ce smartphone de gigaset on va
aller tester des optiques directement
pour l'iphone disent donc je suis équipé
d'un iphone disent tous qu'il faut des
optiques de rhinau chi donc on va les
tester et on abuse allez voir ça va être
super cool dans l'iphone disent quoi il
est juste là on va aller aussi testé à
notre objectif pour iphone 200 marques
qui est ici donc on a pas mal de choses
collaborent ensemble dont je vous invite
à faire qu'une seule chose tout de suite
maintenant si c'est pas déjà fait c'est
à vous abonner activer la cloche comme
ça vous saurez tout des qu'on va parler
de super matos et tout de suite on va
parler de samsung
quelques jours il ya eu la présentation
du galaxy note 9 et à l'occasion de
cette fameuse présentation sens où nous
a présenté sa nouvelle enceinte
d'ailleurs sa première enceinte
connectés intelligente galaxy au malheur
galaxiens à c'est une espèce dans ça
quand il peut cylindrique cette manière
là sur trois pieds qui à l'intérieur pas
moins de six haut parleurs disposés tout
autour un subwoofer pour envoyer un
petit peu grave et un peu de basses et 8
micro à l'intérieur alors il faut savoir
que c'est une enceinte mono sur de la
stéréo il en faut 2 c'est pas du tout
l'adn de ce genre de produits l'intérêt
d'avoir six haut parleurs c'est vraiment
lorsque vous le posez au mieux de votre
pièce pour envoyer du son un peu tous
les côtés et l'intérêt des huits micro
il est plutôt double le premier c'est de
pouvoir entendre ce que vous allez dire
ce que vous allez par les habitent
qu'ils aient l'intelligence artificielle
de sinthiou messager vous détailler
d'ici quelques secondes et la fonction
audio la plus intéressante de ces micro
c'est vraiment devenir capter le son
réfléchis c'est à dire que vous le
positionner n'importe dans une pièce par
exemple le son va partir par là vous
avez un mur leçon va être réfléchie par
le mur il être captée par micro le temps
qui va s'écouler entre moment où
l'enceinte envoie le son est où le son
lui ai réfléchi au micro qui permettra
de calculer la distance avec le muret de
vraiment optimiser le volume sonore par
rapport à votre mur et ça dans l'espace
complet de votre pièce comme ça l'an 5
sera exactement où sont les murs où sont
les espaces réfléchissant casse qui
réfléchit plus vraiment optimisé le tout
par rapport à d'autres pièces c'est pas
la première enceinte à le faire via
notamment le pote d'apple qu'il fait
mais c'est intéressant ça m'est vraiment
montrer le côté intelligent de ce genre
d'enceinte
en tout cas intelligents qui font
vraiment optimisé leçons ont par rapport
à votre pièce fois positif de cette
enceinte c'est la forme d'espèces de
coupole qui est vraiment jolie faisait
pas mal sur le trépied c'est sympa
maintenant il ya vraiment rond point
négatif un gros point je trouve que
c'est un point négatif d'un point de vue
design vous avez le câble qui ressort
énormément parce que ce n'est pas sur
une enceinte qui va jusqu'en bas sur un
socle comme survol par contre on se
retrouve sur une salle qui est du coût
légèrement surélevé avec ses pieds il ya
un côté très esthétique mais le problème
c'est que le câble noir vous le voyez
vous voyez vraiment passé
c'est pas ce qu est plus beau mais bon
ça paraît en tout cas ça me saoule mais
d'avoir une enseigne qui se différencie
la concurrence et ça c'est pas mal alors
je vous parlais big bill bixby c'est
l'intelligence artificielle de samsung
il était présenté en même temps que les
galaxy s suite et suit plus le gros
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui bixby
n'est toujours pas en français si vous
parlez en deuil si vous parlez chinois
vous pourrez profiter de bigbig sans
aucun problème
si vous parlez uniquement français vous
allez tranche mans limité alors
rassurez-vous believe arriva français et
d'ici quelques temps d'ailleurs on
repart est très franchement parce que
viendra la conférence oman novembre des
développeurs de samsung donc à ce moment
là on aura davantage d'informations sur
la river
de bigby en français donc je vous invite
à rester connectés et à vous abonner
parce qu'on en reparlera bien évidemment
à ce moment là ce qui est très
intéressant c'est effectivement de se
rendre compte que ça me fout mais
rajouter un élément supplémentaire à son
écosystème parce que samsung fabrique
pas uniquement des smartphones ou des
anciens connectés j'imagine que vous le
savez samsung s'est bien évidemment des
smartphones maintenant une personne
connectée des tablettes des ordinateurs
des réfrigérateurs des téléviseurs des
aspirateurs des machines à laver des
micros enfin tout un ensemble de
produits complets un écosystème vraiment
complet pour la maison donc l'intérêt si
vous voulez d'avoir une enceinte
connectés c'est vraiment d'apporter un
élément central dans votre maison vous
allez poser votre recette collectée et
vous allez parler à digby au travers
cette enceinte
c'est donc le centre névralgique de
l'intelligence artificielle de samsung
tous ces objets sont interconnectés
grâce à smart 6 martigues c'est le
protocole aliotti de samsung ayew 6 et
internet of things l'internet des objets
c'est la dernière grande révolution
d'internet c'est vraiment la possibilité
d'avoir tous ces objets physiques
interconnectés grâce au web et donc ce
martin vous permet par pas mal de choses
elle vous permet de connecter une
enceinte qui va centraliser avec d'ex
bilatéraux artificielle donc déjà
pouvoir piloter votre en cinq jeux vous
de la musique choisir les titres que
vous voulez passer d'un morceau à
l'autre monte baisser le son passer des
appels téléphoniques également à partir
de 7 ans simple vous êtes pouvoir
rajouter des éléments dans votre liste
de courses bixby y ajoute ma bulle et
digby rajoute mois une bouteille
ou ce que tu veux directement dedans
vous allez pouvoir envoyer des messages
à votre famille à vos amis vous êtes pas
demandé bigbee d'afficher ce qui se
passe dans le salon le film qui est dans
votre salon directement sans votre
réfrigérateur derrière et pas mal de
choses qu'on peut imaginer des exemples
qui sont illustrés son site de samsung
et c'est assez révélateur c'est vraiment
intéressant pour montrer ce qu'on peut
faire avec tout ça pour continuer sur
smart things imaginez vous êtes en train
de faire les courses vous avez votre
galaxy parce que forcément il nous
faudra un smartphone de samsung vous
avez donc un galaxy quels qu'ils soient
qui nous entraîne faire vos courses vous
avez donc votre liste de courses
synchroniser avec votre réfrigérateur
d'or vous avez la complète alors tout le
monde va pas voir la complète tout de
suite mais petit à petit on va s'équiper
puis ces produits vont venir quand même
plus abordable un peu moins cher donc
dans quelques années on y sera quasiment
tous pas forcément chez samsung en tout
cas sur ces objets connectés
imaginez donc vous avez donc votre
smartphone vous êtes en train de
regarder votre liste de courses et vous
dites ah mince et j'ai oublié de marquer
par exemple si j'ai du lait ou si j'ai
pas du lait ce que vous faites et vous
connecter à votre réfrigérateur grâce à
votre interface samsung et vous regarder
grâce aux caméras que vous avez
intérieur de votre réfrigérateur
si vous avez du lait oui ou non et c'est
en ça que ce protocole de connexion
intelligent est vraiment intéressant on
va donc tout l'intérêt d'une enceinte
connectés comme une galaxie home qui va
venir vraiment trouvé sa place au coeur
de votre foyer vous allez pouvoir mettre
en place des routines allumer la lumière
à telle heure phare sonner une alarme
démarrer la machine à laver la nuit
lorsque vous allez payer moins cher en
électricité des pouvoir piloter
l'ensemble de votre maison avec smart
sim vous allez pouvoir déverrouiller
distance votre porte pour faire pas mal
de choses et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant
samsung fait donc un pas de plus vers la
maison connectée il avait déjà une offre
qui était extrêmement large et là ils
viennent vraiment posée l'élément
central alors pour l'instant on n'a
absolument aucun prix sur cette enceinte
connectés ni aucune date de
disponibilité
je vous invite donc une fête plus à
rester connectés parce que on en parlera
très très prochainement dès qu'on aura
des éléments supplémentaires et d'y
rester connecté parce que les enseignes
connecté on va en parler on va en parler
amazonie qu on va tester très très
prochainement donc rester là vous allez
voir on va beaucoup parler de la maison
connectée la maison du futur on va
essayer de comprendre un peu comment
tous ces autres
on peut vraiment interagir ensemble
d'une façon intelligente on va parler
des sûr toujours de smartphones de
tablettes ordinateurs on va aussi
pourquoi pas parler de réfrigérateurs
connectés ça peut vraiment avoir un sens
pour voir à quoi va ressembler votre vie
numérique d'ici quelques années parce
que qu'on le veuille ou non tous les
objets qu'on va acheter d'ici quelques
années seront tous connectés
on n'aura pas juste des réfrigérateurs
bête comme on les actuellement tous les
constructeurs vont mettre des écrans
avec des solutions intégrées pour
pouvoir les connecter à tous vos objets
et de toute façon au qu'on le veuille ou
non on n'a pas pouvoir trop et coupé
dont je vous invite à rester connectés
dernière info cette enceinte a été
développé par aq agea kg et fabrique des
objets audio depuis de nombreuses années
j'avais très longtemps un cas saccagé et
la qualité sonore est vraiment top
à cannes j'ai été acheté par samsung ça
repart mais effectivement d'avoir une
entreprise dédié à l'audio d'excellente
qualité et normalement ce galaxy on
devrait plutôt pas mal en termes de
qualité audio ils ont mis en place un
partenariat d'explosifs haye pour être
sûrs dans un premier temps qu'ils
élaborent un catalogue très large de
musique puis c'est vraiment une caution
morale à samsung parce qu'on imagine que
spotify va pas les faire un partenariat
depuis entreprises proposent une
enceinte de qualité moyenne
donc c'est comme une espèce de label
certifié validé par spotify
voilà pour ces infos sur le galaxy home
de samsung dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez ce qu'une enceinte comme ça
pourrait vous intéresser
est-ce que vous avez déjà achetées soit
en amazone échos soit un apple ipod
est-ce que ce galaxy au d'ici quelques
temps qu'elle sera disponible pourrait
vous intéresser
dites moi ce que vous en pensez
directement 20 ans commenté api je vous
invite une fois de plus à rester
connectés parce que je vous emmène avec
nous en vacances alors il y aura un peu
moins de vidéos publiées il aura
forcément une vidéo tous les jours
pendant
dizaine de jours parce que j'aime aussi
aller profiter un peu pour me détendre
parce que croyez moi la rentrée d'être
hyper chargé d'ici quelques jours
dans moins d'un mois je vous emmène avec
moi il fa à partir de fin août début
septembre on va lancer la saison 2 avec
un tout nouveau format revue corrigée et
améliorée dont croyez-moi va y avoir
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui
vont arriver beaucoup de travail pour
moi donc là je vais me la couler douce
farniente je vous revenir bronzer mais
c'est prévu pas mal de choses tous cas
derrière on va le tester en vacances
donc restez connectés merci à vous
d'être pigeon plus nombreux est ce que
jean plus nombreux sur la chaîne ne
s'est pas laissé toutes vos questions
suggestions intéressant directement
banques aux motards et puis à me
rejoindre sur les réseaux sociaux a dit
yves monsieur underscore re tweeter
monsieur re facebook tout ce que vous
voulez le asha peu partout merci à vous
et à très bientôt vous embrasse aux
dépens du chao
[Musique]